ないんです 今日はそれほど難しくしないんです
そういう まあ今日のテーマはいわゆる Meet Yourself ということで
自分に会ってみたらどうでしょうか
とか 会ったことないでしょう
他人にはいくらでも会ったことあるんですけど
それからこの自分を発見するために
自分を観察してね 自分を発見するためにどうすればよしかという
少々この前の話は結構ややこしかったんですから
できればそちらにもちょっと具体的な説明はいたします
そういうことで まあどんどん続けていきます
それはまあ ある日本訳ですね
正直に生きるとはどういうことっていうことをね
次です で それから正直というタイトルで今日の話は持っていきます
正直っていうのは 自分の気持ち通りに行動できることですね
私が定義しなくても まあお分かりになっていると思います
それからもう一つも感情を素直に表すこと
自分の感情 考え方を素直に表すことをできれば
まあそれぐらいでしょうね
正直っていうのは 何か付け加えることがございますか
それ以外は はい  嘘をつかない
正直ですかね 嘘言いたいことは正直だったらどうしますか
正直っていうのは 何か辞書を引いて読みますとね
2つの意味があって 一つは嘘をつかないことです
もう一つは正しく素直に生きること
正しく あの字の通りという 2つの意味が辞書に書いて
でも字の通り見ればまっすぐってもう正しくまっすぐですからね
まあそれは辞書の意味で
それは俗世間の考え方で
こちらではまあ一応心理学的なところですから
そういうところで何か付け加えることがございますかね
あの 大体自分の気持ち通りに行動できることですよ
で  2番目は 自分の感情を素直に
表せるんだったら まあそれはこの辞書の正直じゃなくて
自分 仏教は自分の勉強だからね
だから自分の正直なんです
だから嘘を言う人も自分には正直なんです
自分が嘘を言いたいんです
だから正直な気持ちで嘘を言ってるんです
まあ大体は心理学的に自分というところを中心にして考えると
まあこの 2つだとは思います
はい それから辞書にもあったような辞書にあったのは正直のごまかしなんです
正直の定義じゃないんです
あれは希望を言ってるんです
他人がこうしてほしいという
ですから 正直のごまかしということがございます
普通 正直とは何かと理解していない
まず正直って何なのかと
もう誰も理解していない
ただ正直 正直 正直というだけで
一体全体正直って何なのかと
この定義は世間では時と場合によって変わってしまう
この世間で正直ということも
その時と場合によって変わるんですよ
あのできるだけこういうものはすごい具体的に
この仏教というのは生きてることの勉強だから
具体的にご自分の人生の中で自分がアンタ正直じゃない
もっと正直になれとか言った場合は何を意味したかと
もう考えてほしいんです
時々子供に言うんですよ
もっと正直になりなさいよと
その場合は何か子供が言わないでごまかしてるんですね
正直に言いなさいよと言うんです
正直になったら言わないことなんですけど
子供は で あるいはその子供
同じことも家のことは平気で他人に言ってしまえば
大体この 4歳  7歳  8歳ぐらいになってくると
子供はよく喋りますからね
もう何でもかんでも平気で喋る
で 大人が結構もう戸惑っちゃいますけどね
その場合は本当にいろんなことを言って欲しくないでしょうに
だから時と場合によって変わるんで
例えば子供はもう掃除機にいなさいと言ったところで遊んでばっかりしていると
君のわがままではうまくいかないんだよと
人の話も聞きなさいと言うでしょう
その場合は掃除機はダメはダメだと言ってるんですね
だから私たちはまあ その時その時で掃除機の定義を変えるんですよ
曖昧な意味で使用している
実際 掃除機って何なのかっていうことは誰もわかってないんです
すごい意味が曖昧なんです
それは曖昧な意味で使っているんです
従って ただのスローガンになっている
だから世の中にある掃除機という言葉は単なるスローガンですよ
誰も実際に じゃあ掃除機な人間になるっていうことはどういうことかとわかってますかね
わかってないでしょうね
しかし 掃除機はいいでしょということスローガンなんです
掃除機はいいでしょうって言ったら
掃除機って何なのかとわかってなくてね
いいっていうことは言えないし
で 掃除機ではなくても良いと誰も言わない
それよく大事なポイントなんです
誰一人も言わないんです
掃除機でなくてもいいんだよと
これって何でしょうかね
普段誰も掃除機に生きようとしていないのです
次の私のポイントは 人間というのは誰も別に掃除機に生きようとはしていないんです
だったらみんな別にそんなに掃除機に生きようとしていないにも関わらず
だったらね 掃除機でなくてもいいよと言った方が楽なのに
それは言わない 女性なんかは結構頑張りますよ
掃除機でない生き方には
例えば嫌な人とでも結婚したら頑張りますよ
もうとにかくうまくいくようにと
何年でも もうやがてうまくいく場合もあるし
それでも年経ったところでうまくいかない場合もありますよ
その場合 私から見れば
その女性が掃除機じゃないんです
だから掃除機でなくてもいいということで頑張ってるんです
まあやがてまあなんとかうまくいくんじゃないかなと
だからそれが私はただもう辛口言ってるわけじゃなくて
実際人間やってることなんです
男性の方もね まあ上司がすっごい気に入らなくて
もう嫌なんですけど いつでもはいはいはいはいと言いながらペコペコとしながら随分もう従っているような顔をしているでしょうね
それも掃除機の生き方じゃないでしょうね
でも逆にそれが正しいと言ってるでしょうね
まあいろいろあるんだけど
自分が自分なりに頑張っているんだと
会社で  [背景音楽]嫌なこといっぱいあるんですけど
とにかくまあそこはもうなんとか気にしないようにと頑張ってるんだ
だからそれも正直な生き方じゃないんです
ということは 世の中で大体もう誰でも正直に生きてるわけじゃないんです
子供にしたっても 親の顔を見ながら
先生の顔を見ながらいろいろやってるんだから
それも正直な生き方と言えますかね
うん だったら正直でなくてもいいと言った方がいいのに
誰も言わない  そこら辺はすごいわかりやすい
実は正直になってはならないと言うべきところですが
本当は人は正直になったら困ると言うべきところですとか
逆を言ってるんです 正直になりなさいと
世の中っていつでもそういうことでうまくいかないんですよ
正直は悪 それからちょっと仏教的な説明で
みんな正直になりなさいと言いますけど
そうならなくてもいいんですよ
別に 結局はみんなそうでしょうし
正直な人間いないし だったら仏教的に言うならば
正直というものは悪ならよくない
自分の正直は悪だったら
やっぱり正直になったら困るでしょう
例えば ものすごくもう人が憎しみでも見たくもないんだと
できれば殺してやりたいという人が正直に生きると困るでしょうに
たまったもんじゃないでしょうに
だから正直が悪だったら
やっぱりこれこの正直はよくないんですよ
それから正直線ならあってほしいということで
が この判断はありません
ということは 上の 2つの判断もあまり誰もしません
だから 正直は善であるならば
良いことであるならば
人を助けてあげたいとか
みんなの役に立つように生きてみたいとか
人を悩ませたくないとかね
そういう本来の気持ち
それだったら素晴らしいでしょうね
それだったら正直に生きてほしいんですよ
しかし 問題はこの判断がないんですよ
みんな正直正直と言うだけで
この心を この正直というものは善か悪かと誰も判断しないんです
だからこの あまり私は別に哲学を言ってるわけじゃなくて
我々は日常生活する中で生々しく生きてる世界のことを言ってるんです
だから あんまり難しく考える必要ないんです
いつでも単純で素朴で考えた方がいいんです
自分に聞いてみてください
自分が一度でも正直というものが善か悪かと考えたことがありますかね
一度もないと思いますよ
それ言ってるんで その判断はありませんと
正直は善だって考えてます
大体は一般的な考え方はそうなんです
それは我々にただ刷り込まれてるだけ
わかってない人々に それはあります
我々は思い込んでいるんです
正直っていうのは善だと
でも実際 生々しく我々の人生を研究すると
そうじゃないんです 人を殺す人は正直にやってるんですよ
それが だから世間がいつでも逆を言ってて
我々に正直になりな それは素晴らしいことやと我々に刷り込まれてるんです
それはどちらかというと固定概念なんです
社会の 世界の 今現れた問題ではないんですよ
そういう単語ができた時点からも世の中にあることなんです
仏教では正直を悪と見なして
それを善に変えることを勧める
それを覚えてください
これは仏教のね 初期仏教の講義ですから
仏教はそれについて何言うかというと
結論はこれなんです 正直は悪と見なしてるんです
それで終わらない それ善に変えてくださいと
だから仏教からも正直になることは悪くないんです
それで仏教は世間一般的に言ってる常識にそういうふうに戻るんです
世間では何も理解しないで
正直は善だ みんな正直になるべきだと言いながら
正直で生活する人は一人もいない
それで世の中いろんなトラブルが起こる
私たちはにはもう後輩を躾することをなかなかできない
自分も随分いい加減だから
ある時は正直にやったことを褒めるし
ある時は正直にやったことに怒鳴るし
どなって正直に生きてみなさいとまた言うし
言われる側はむちゃくちゃ混乱するでしょうに
しかし言う側もわかってないでしょうに
ですから この 仏教はそこら辺を問題解決して
正直っていうのは悪と見なしてくださいと
で それで終わらないで
その悪を善に善に変えてくださいと
そうすると正直に生きていられる
それで世の中の言葉に
あまりにも間違って言わなくて
大胆に違う言葉を言うと
かなり混乱するんだからね
そこでまあ 正直な生き方はとてもいい生き方だと仏教でも言ってます
でもそれは世間の考え方に乗ったわけじゃないんです
それだけ気をつけてください
かなりの工程をプロセスを経てから言っていることであって
だからみんな言うでしょ
まあブッダが言うことは大体常識的なことでも誰でもわかりますよと
単純やとかね 実はそうじゃないんです
かなりのプロセスがあって
かなりの心の成長があってから言うことなんです
はい まあ簡単ですから次に行きましょう
正直っていうのはつあります
まあそれさえもあまりご存知じゃないでしょう
自分に正直 他人に正直
行為に正直 それから信じている
または教えられている生き方に正直っていうですね
で この 4番目 何かもう単純な言葉にしようかなと思ったんですけど
なかなか単純な言葉見つからなかったんですね
まあ主義に正直と言った方がいいかもね
それするともっと説明する羽目になりますからね
まあ自分に正直っていうことは大体わかりますね
自分の気持ちによって行動する
だから自分の気持ちが言うことはする
それは自分に正直 他人に正直っていうことはちょっとわかりにくいんですね
でもこれも大体世の中でよくあります
他人のことはすごい真剣に
真面目に その人の気持ちを考えて
その人の気持ちは損なわないように
機嫌が悪くならないように必死で他人に尽くす
自分の気持ちを抑えて
それもあるでしょ いつでも自分の気持ちに正直に生きてるわけじゃないんだからね
時々自分の気持ちは置いておいて
[音楽]人の気持ちに合わせてそれに乗って行動する
これどちらでもいい場合も悪い場合もあります
だから自分に正直と言ったっても
わがままやら怒りやら憎しみやら感情が起きて
正直に人を怒鳴ったり
人に迷惑をかけたりしちゃうと
正直は正直なんですけど
いいわけじゃないんですよ
他人に正直も いつでもいいわけじゃないんです
で わかりやすい例は 麻原のグループに入った人々はみんな正直なんです
で 話してみたっても 全然嫌な気にはならないんですよ
いい人々だなとどうも思ってしまうんです
正直な人々やと もう犯罪まで起こしているのに
だからそのグループはこの日本
日本の社会現象を明確に表している極端な例なんです
だから どんな どんなものでも極端にしないとわからないんですよ
ごちゃ混ぜでは だからもう全部もう分けて分けて極端に取ってもらわないと
それで見事に ある若者のグループが他人に正直になることってどういうことかと
徹底的に自我を捨てて
自分というものを全部捨てて
麻原という人に完全に
何て言いますか 身を任す
だから立派な医者なのに
それ医者だったら自分でしょ
自分が立派に大学で勉強して研究して
明確にすごい人を治すことをすごく勉強して
もともとも人のことをよく気にする人なのに
それが入れ替えて他人に正直ということになったところで人殺しに行ったんです
これは大体は医者にできる仕事じゃないんです
人殺すことは全然教えても訓練させてもないんです
人を殺す人を人を憎しむ人っていうのは医者にならないんですよ
初めからその学問さえも嫌なんです
大体人を治したいとかね
治った時の喜びの顔を見たいとか
人を助けたいという夢を持って子供たちが医学部に入るんです
しかし 他人に正直になると
また別なんですね 自分を捨てるんです
大体信仰で目指す宗教で目指すとこは
他人に正直になりなさいということなんですね
自分を捨てなさいと それはいいわけじゃないんです
そこで他人に正直に 日本の昔もね
これはよく日本であるんですよ
昔も特攻隊と言って自分を殺したでしょうに
その場合も他人に正直
それで今もパレスチナ人やらね
自爆しながら 宗教のために
自分の国民のためにということで自分が死ぬんですよ
それももう他人に正直ということなんです
だから 特に神を立てている宗教の場合は
徹底的に神に 何て言いますか
依存ではなくて 頼ること
完全に期待するんです
完全に頼ること 自我を完全に捨てることを
期待しているんです それがいわゆる原理主義ということになっているんです
それが大変な危険なことなんです
なぜ危険かというと この他人が何者かということによりますよ
麻原が悪い人でしたから
麻原に完全に頼った人々は罪を犯しちゃったんです
もしその他人様が本当に立派な人であるならば
その人に従った方がいいんですよ
一番もそうなんですよ
自分が本当に清らかな気持ちでいるならば
慈しみの気持ちでならば
自分に正直になった方がいいんです
しかし 嫉妬やら憎しみやら出てきちゃうと
やっぱり正直でない方がありがたいんです
ごまかした方がいいんです
他人に正直な場合でも同じことで
他人が本当に完全たる人格だったら
もう何も言わず従いなさいと
それお釈迦様も言ってるんですよ
心を清らかにして 欲がなくて
完全に智慧があって そういう人が見つけたら
すべて捨てて その人に一緒に生きなさいよと
その場合も他人に完全に頼るっていうことなんです
お釈迦様は神に頼るっていうことは全く言ってない
人間のことを言ってるんです
いつでも仏教はすごい具体的な話だから
神に頼ってしまっても
見たことでも会ったことでも舐めたこと何もないでしょうに
だからもうどうすればいいかわからないでしょうね
結局我々は神に頼ると思って
誰かが書いた もう全く整理も否定もない
思考もきちんと整理していない
はっきりと論理工程も成り立ってない
何かのテキストに頼っているだけだから
それは書いた人間に頼ってるんですよ
だから 本の中で論理的なシステムが成立してなければ
その人の思考パターンでしょ
だから我々は曖昧 中途半端
精神的な問題がある人に頼ってるんです
その場合は 決して神に頼ってるわけじゃないんです
かわいそうに 本人は正直ですよ
自爆する人でも キリスト教の方々
昔は結構悪やってましたからね
神に正直で で 本人はね
罪を犯す本人が正直ですよ
他人に正直なんです 他人って何なのかというと
いわゆる神の言葉という何とかのテキストなんです
それを読んでみると あまり理屈成り立ってない
道徳はしっかりしていない
はっきり人間にどう生きるべきかという道は言ってないということは
作った人の考え方でしょう
作った人はそれをはっきりわかってない
作った人間が それで曖昧な人間に頼ったということになります
だから社会的な問題は起こすんです
しかし これどちらでも悪くないんです
自分の心がきれいであるならば
自分に正直は素晴らしい
もし立派な人間が見つけたならば
知恵のある 道徳的に完璧
立派な人格者見つけたら
まあ全部捨ててその人と一緒になった方が自分も立派な人間になります
他人のおかげで だからお釈迦様もこのどちらでも推薦するんですよ
一人でも良い人間見つからなかったら一人で生活しなさいと
サチェラベタニパカンサハヤンサッディビハリンチャーディヒランという偈がありますね
サチェラベタ 見つかるならば
パハエサッバーニパリッシャヤーニ
すべての束縛 何でも捨てて
その人と一緒に生きなさいよと
チャレイヤテーナッタマノーサティーマ
彼と心喜んで生活しなさいと一緒に
ノーチエラベタニパカンサハヤンサッディ
サハヤンサッディンチャーリヴィハーリディーラント
もし見つからなかったら
そういう一緒に生きるために智慧のある性格の良い人間見つからなかったら
一人で生活しなさい 全くも一人で孤独で
仏教では孤独っていうのを尊い孤独ということなんです
エイカヴィハーリって一人でいるっていうことは
俗世間でいう孤独じゃないんです
それは情けないんですね
みんな孤独やということは
こちらで孤独っていうのはすごい立派な生き方なんです
自分が心は清らかで 掃除機で真剣で
善はなんなのかと探し求めている人で
世の中を見たら誰もそういう気持ちはないんですね
仲間がいないだったらしっかり強く自分の正しい道を歩む
それが仏教でいう孤独なんです
決して情けない生き方じゃないんです
すごい大胆な生き方なんです
だからお釈迦様はどちらでもいいとは言っています
3番目 行為に正直 それまたわからないでしょう
まあ行為っていうのは
その都度その都度自分がやる仕事なんです
それで具体的な例で考えましょう
で 女性から例を出します
女性がいて 料理を作らなくちゃいけない
相手が態度が悪くてね
何か作ってくれとか調子で頼む
それは自分人間として自分の尊厳をやっぱり害しているんで
そうやって偉そうに頼むと
そうすると その女性はすごく嫌な気持ちになるんです
本当のところは料理なんかは作りたくない
しかし 作らせいられるわけできない
どうしても作らなくちゃいけない
その場合は 嫌で中途半端で食べられないまずいものを作るということではなくて
この行為に 正直に すごく丁寧に
しっかり見事にいい料理を作ってみせる
その場合は 自分が自分の仕事にやるならば完璧にやるぞと
腕を振って批判を受けられないようにしっかりやるんだよと
食べる人は誰でもいいやと気にしないと
その場合は別に自分に正直というわけでもないでしょうに
相手に言われたんだから
しっかり料理作ってあげなくちゃいけないという気持ちもないでしょうに
仕事に正直 行為に正直
それは勉強した方がいいんです
いつでも 時々はあんまりお金もらうわけでもないんだから
自分手抜きをする それはとんでもないことなんです
人が仕事にお金くれてもくれなくても
自分に与えられた仕事だから
それはプライドを持ってしっかりやった方がいいんです
もし手抜きしたならば
これ自分の人生に汚点が入ったことになるんです
自分が損したことになります
これからボランティア的に自分何ももらわないで
自分から貢献する場合でも
いい加減で投げやりで
まあなんとかすればいいやという感じでやったりする
それはよくないんですよ
自分がよくない人間になってしまうんです
投げ出したりして 投げやりの気持ちで
だから 相手が認めようか認めないか
ご褒美あげる もらうかもらわなかろうか
それと関係なく とにかく自分がそれをやらなくちゃいけない
そのそれだったら それ自分の能力を全部使って
もう精一杯やるということは行為に正直
それすごい立派なことなんです
で まあだからといって
いつでも行為に正直ということ完全善というわけじゃないんですよ
これもやっている行為次第だから
例えばもう泥棒してくれと
自分仕事するしている店で宝石があるんだからね
それ取れるように協力してくれと言っちゃうと
全く見つからないようにすごい見事に
泥棒が入られるように全部用意してあげたりすると
もう仕事は完璧なんですけど
そういう正直さは良くない
だから行為に正直ということも
まあやっぱりそちらでも善悪があるんです
しかし そのつの掃除掃除機は決して悪いと断言できませんし
良いとも断言できません
それを覚えてほしい それから 4番目
それは主義に正直ということですね
短い言葉で言えば そうでなきゃ困りますよ
例えば自民党の方がいて
自民党の政治論には正直じゃない
と言うと なかなかね うまくいかんでしょうに
信頼できないでしょうに
宗教の場合も同じことで
まあ真面目に信じてない
中途半端とかね ほとんど疑っているとか
でも自分がその宗教の人だと名乗ったりすると
まあ結局はね うまくいかない
だから人間には何か生き方
何か主義 何か信仰 何かの哲学っていうのはある
それはだいたい外から受け入れるものだから
生まれつきあるわけじゃないんです
私たちの宗教は生まれつき付いているものではなくて
生まれてから勉強して取るものですからね
だから主義っていうのは
まあ生まれてからもう体に入るもので
その場合もそれに正直だったらありがたいんですよ
結局は 自分にとってもやりやすいんです
だからといって いつでも完全にいいというわけじゃないんです
その主義自体が曖昧で危険だったら
良くないんですよ 一般的には世の中ではアメリカ主義には賛成はしていますけど
大胆にアメリカ主義だったらとんでもない代物でしょうに
みんなに迷惑をかけるでしょうに
共産主義もそうでしょうに
あまりにも共産主義に正直になっちゃうと
もう人殺しでも何でもやっちゃうということになる
だから主義自体が不完全で悪いものだったら
主義に正直になることも大変よくない
それまた麻原の場合でも
その教えは素晴らしいと
と言った途端 どこで何が素晴らしいともわかってないし
欠点も見つからないし
ただまあ妄信するだけ
だからといって主義に正直ということは悪いわけないんですよ
この主 教え自体が完全たる教えであるならば
完全たる智慧で教えられたものであるならば
人類のことは完全に心配して
人類のために教えているものであるならば
また真理事実であるならば
それに正直になるしかないでしょうに
他の道は 言っていることは本当であるならば
そういうことで どちらでも良い場合も悪い場合もある
だからこの四つの正直は仏教でも認めている
例えばお釈迦様おっしゃった教えも
これが真理だと いくらか納得いって
わかっているところもわかっていないところも
まあブッダに説かれたものだから
もう別に問題はありませんと
心配する必要は全くないんだと
その通りにやってみる
そうと見たら 本当に人生はうまくいきますよ
その場合 全部わかっているわけじゃないんです
ただ 教えに正直だけ しかし
その教えが問題ないんだから
問題は起きません それである人がこの私と
このファンダメンタリズムという原理主義についてちょっと話しちゃったんです
自分の国の新聞などでも
この原理主義ということには大変良くないということで
いろいろ言ってるんです
ある神父さんが記事があって
結構研究して書いてあったもので
神学校の教授で で キリスト教でも原理主義はとんでもないんだと
イスラム教にしたっても
原理主義なんかはとんでもないことやと
仏教にしたってもとんでもないことやということで
いろいろちゃんとそれなりに資料を出して
結構長い記事でしたけどね
で 書いてあったんですけど
それで私と喋った人も
もう最近なんかこの仏教の人々も原理主義になろうとしているのではないかと
なんでこのお坊さんがそういうふうな話するんですかと
お坊さんのくせに仏教をわかってないんではないかというふうなことを言って
あなたもどうでしょうかと
それについてちょっと反論でも出してみればと
そしたら私は彼に あなたは原理主義って何なのかとわかってるんですかと
まあそれわかってからいいんだよと
教えが間違っているならば
原理主義は完全に危険だと
教えが正しければ原理主義でないと危険だと
それを覚えておきなさいよと
教えが完璧なものだったら
原理主義にならないと危険です
教えがガタガタだったら原理主義が危険です
いい加減みんなあれは悪い
これは悪いって言うんじゃなくてね
仏教的な智慧で何でも明確に分析して喋れないと
それで私は彼に あなたはブッダの教えもいい加減で中途半端で曖昧だと思ってますか？と
そうは思ってないんだよと
だったらなんで仏教原理主義は悪いんですかと
それはあなた方が仏教をわからないだけですと
仏教の原理主義になった人は誰にも迷惑をかけませんと
なぜならば覚えておきなさいよと
人が鋸で自分の体を切っても
相手に対して嫌な気持ちさえも起こすなよというのがブッダの教えだよと
相手を殺すか憎しむか
恨むというところじゃないんです
どうせ嫌な気持ちは現れるでしょうね
生で鋸で切る場合は その場合ででも
相手に対して嫌な気持ちを作るなよと
それが慈しみだよと 言ってるのはブッダなんで
すごい極端な言い方でしょうに
でも慈しみっていうのはそうやって極め尽くさなくちゃいけないんです
そういう人が人に迷惑をかけると思いますか？自分にちょっと悪口言っただけで
自分を批判しただけで
自分の財産ちょっと持っていっただけで
それで自分の国では仏教はものすごい
もう長い間かなりもう攻撃されちゃって
ダメージ受けちゃって
全部もうからくりで裏でいろんなことをやって壊す
破壊しようとしているんです
それで仏教をろくに勉強していないお坊さんたちはそれに乗ってしまって
さらに破壊しようとしているんです
守ろうと思って 誰もブッダの教えはわかってないんです
誰かがもうお寺を自分たちで奪おうとしても 「
じゃあどうぞ持っていってください」と言えばそれだけのことでしょうに
あんた方それでよければと
国の心臓みたいにみんな大事にしているブッダシジというところで
もうテロたちがすごい爆弾起こして
もうかなり人々死んじゃったんです
いつでも大勢人がいるところだから
あのすごい歴史的な建物にもヒビが入って
表の方はもう壊れましたけど
お釈迦様の歯を奉ってるところにはもう何も危害はなかったんですけど
それでも昔の小さな建物を加工して新しい建物を作ってガードしているんです
昔の建物っていうのはもうただの土で作っているものなんです
そちらにもヒビが入ったんで
でも あの竹とかいろいろ作って
そこで枠をそこでその中に土を埋め込んで作っているものだから
もうちょっともう入れるだけで問題はないんですけど
だから信者さんが花を持ってお線香を持って行くところに
もういきなり爆弾を仕掛けて
車でね いきなり入ってきて爆破させたんですけど
その時はやっぱり待ち構えているんですよ
外国から来て それからもうみんな攻撃するでしょうと
復讐するでしょうと それが大いに世界的に報道してやるぞと
仏教とはこんなものやと
みんなもうあっちこっちからもうニュース
マスコミが来て待ち構えているんです
だからテロ活動も向こうは知っているんだから
最初からもう 世界のマスコミは
でもお坊さんたちもその時に大統領もね
たった一言葉ね 「復讐するなよ」と
仏教とは何があっても落ち着いているものやと
それで一人の人でも そのちょっと隣もいろんな人々いたんです
このテロの人々が商売やったりして
何のこともない それで 1日待っていて 2
日待っていて  1週間待っていて
何も起こりません 一応もうまあ
遺産 国際遺産だからね
その場所は で 政府はさっと全部閉鎖して立ち入り禁止にして
でも修復するためにはものすごいお金かかる
お金もない それで 1週間経ったところで
誰も何も反論も何もない
復讐もない どうなったかというと
見事にイスラムの人々は大金寄付したんです
キリスト教の人々もみんな寄付したんです
いろんなみんな宗教と何の関係もなく
後で寄付して 政府もお金出して全部修復しちゃったんです
見事に修復して それからまたオープンしたんです
みんなに それが仏教的なやり方で素晴らしいと
その時私はいなかったんですけど
ああ これ それこそこの人間はまだまだ捨てたものではありませんと
もうたとえあのお寺を平らにしたっても
別にいいんじゃないんですかね
それほどやりたければ
それについて なんで別に復讐したり攻撃したりするんですかね
だから仏教 ブッダの原理主義はそういうことなんです
自分を殺しても嫌な気持ちになるなよと
それだったら君 私の教えやってる人じゃないんだよと
これ手紙に言うんですよ
だからブッダの教えが完全だから
なぜ仏教の人々の中でもトラブルばっかしで
いつでも何かトラブル
理由はみんな曖昧 中途半端
教えに正直じゃないんです
教えに正直だったら誰も問題は起こしません
だからこの教えが正しければ
やっぱり原理主義でなきゃダメなんです
教えが曖昧だったら中途半端でいいんです
そこそこでいいところだけ取って
悪いところは見なかったことにする
例えばキリスト教の場合でも
人を助けなさいと そこはいいところで
それだけ取って 私以外誰か死んじゃったなら
ただすまそ あまり気にしない
そういう脅しはという感じでいいでしょうに
人間誰でも人間でしょうと
それでここだけの話なんですけど
私は個人的に知っている人格的に立派な神父さんたちが
みんな信仰曖昧 いい加減なんです
でも人間としてすごい立派なんです
献身的ですごく勉強して
すごくこのまあトレランスというか
寛容的で 誰にでも信頼されて
立派なんですけど よくよく見てみると
全然キリスト教信じてないんじゃないかなと
聖書に言ってる通りではなくて
本人が自分の気持ち通りにやってるんです
それでみんなに信頼される
だからこの教えが曖昧だったら
原理主義はとても危険です
例えば殺すなかれとお釈迦様おっしゃってるでしょうね
それは原理主義的に守ってみれば何が悪いんですかね
敵であろうが誰であろうが殺さない
いかなる場合でも殺すなかれでしょう
でも高麗になってくると
目には目という話をまた取り戻したでしょう
それはイエス様は取り消したんですけど
取り消したんですけど
また戻しちゃうんです
そうすると条件付きで殺す権利になり立つでしょうに
それだったら曖昧なんですね
殺しはないんだよと思ったら
もう軍隊に入れなくなっちゃうんです
軍隊に入る人はいないんだから
その場合は 別になくてもいいんですよ
別に誰を無条件に殺ししませんから
誰も殺さない国は他の国からも攻撃しません
すぐその気持ちはなくなっちゃうんです
日本はいくら平和な国だと言ったって
もしかすると北朝鮮は潰したいという気持ちはあると思いますけど
なぜかというと 原子爆弾作るわもうミサイル作るわということで
これはおっかないんだから
アメリカでもあれを潰すんだったら
みんな日本人がみんな賛成するでしょうに
だからそういう気持ちさえ何であるのかというと
向こうは人を殺す気持ちでいるんだからでしょうに
だから北朝鮮は全く全部開示して
もうもうこんなところじゃないんだと
国は大変だと みんな苦しんでいるんだと
だからみんなできるできるだけところでは助けてくださいと言ったならば
誰でも簡単に出入りできるように国をオープンにしたならば
誰も敵視しないでしょうに
だからそれが人間は生きるべき道なんですけど
誰もやってはないんです
だからずっと世界は危険でしょうし
不安でしょうし だから教えが正しければ
別に教えでなくても お釈迦様おっしゃったのは普遍的な真理だから
別にブッダの考え方ではないんです
あれはあるべき本当の状態を言っているだけ
それだったらやっぱり原理主義はいいということになります
私の個人的な考え方では
ですから この一応皆様にそれ関係ない雑談になりましたけど
正直は四つあるんだということだけ覚えておいてください
これも初めて聞くことだと思います
ただ 一般的に正直正直と言うだけであって
よくよく見るとそうじゃなくて四つあるんです
はい それから なぜ正直になったりならなかったりするのでしょうか
これから全く別なポイントなんです
また我々個人個人のことなんですよ
時々我々は正直になるんです
時々正直じゃないんです
なんでしょうかね それは
それは結局はこの基準はね
この私は正直か正直でないか
正直の道を歩むか 正直でない道を歩むかという
このナビゲーターはこの自己の利益なんです
基準は自己の利益 自己の利益のために正直になるか不正直になるかを決めてしまうんですね
私は全部縮みして書いているんだから
まず説明しておきます
そこで私はある時は正直に行動する
なぜかというと その場合は自己の利益があるんです
自分に対して ある時は正直ではなくてごまかしちゃうんです
なぜかというと それも自分の利益なんです
自分のためなんです だから自分のため
自己の利益という それで決めるんです
人間が本来正直というわけじゃないんです
自己の利益という基準があるんです
それに当てはめてみて
あ 利益になるなと分かったら正直な道を選ぶ
利益になるんだと分かったら不正直な道を選ぶ
それが人間の生き方 だから本来正直といういいものだと
そんな話じゃないんです
人間は正直か不正直なのか分かったものでもない
ただ単に自己の利益という基準で生きていける
生きているんです それで反論成り立つのですよ
みんな自己の利益のみを目指して生きているならば
みんな幸福でしょう 次に書いている四行目ですね
四行目に書いているのはこの反論なんです
しかし 実態は何なのかと
個人個人が自分の利益のみをて生きている
それだったら個人が自分の利益を得ているはずなんです
個人個人が自分の利益を得ているということは
みんな自分の利益を得ているんだということなんです
それだったら人類はみんな幸せでしょうに
幸福でしょうに 成功しているでしょうに
しかし 実態はどうですかね
幸せな人っていうのはほとんどないという状態でしょうね
だから私の話と実態はどうでしょう
なんで合わないんでしょうかね
で 答えは 5番目に書いているんです
人が結局自己の利益とは何かとわかっていないのです
そういうことなんです
自己の利益のために生きて生きているんですけど
それもわかってない 掃除機という言葉をわかってないと同じで
これもまたわかってない
だからわかってないんだったら
自己の利益を得るはずがないんです
だから なんで人は不幸だというと
あれは勘違いしているんです
それは自己の利益だと思って不幸の決断をする
そういうこと はい それで自己の利益についてもうちょっと説明します
利益は主観の判断で決められないのです
これがよく覚えてほしい
私たちは自分の主観で
自分の考え方で自分の利益を考えているんですよ
私がこれを私に対してとてもいいと思いますよと
自分の判断 主観なんです
でも世の中 自分の主観で判断できませんよ
まあ例えば すっごいもう可愛い
美しい豪華なケーキがあるとする
それ美味しいんだから
自分がこれが美味しいんだから食べたら楽しいでしょうと思う
それ自分の利益でしょうね
でもその人にとっては
これが食べるべきかないか別な話でしょうに
ものすごい体の健康状態も悪いんだったら
高血圧からもう糖尿病からもうあらゆる病気が体に付いてるならば食べてはいけないでしょうに
だから食べることは自己の楽しみなんですが
これは主観的に判断するとうまくいかないんです
だから人間みんな自己の利益は主観で判断する
それでは判断できません
例えばもう一つ 薬を飲もうと思ったら
私はこの赤いとピンク色の薬が可愛いんだからこれ飲みたいんだとかね
そんなことでダメでしょうね
それはもう他人が決めるんです
あるいは客観的に決めるものです
この体の病気にはどんな薬が必要かということは
それが自分の利益でしょうね
病気に合う薬を飲むことは自己の利益でしょうね
しかし 自分の病気に合う薬は自分の判断で選ぶものじゃないんです
いかなる結果も原因によるものです
因果法則に沿って客観的に考察しないではしない
人間は 私があれが好き
これが好き 私は音楽家になりたい
私は画家になりたい 私は医者になりたいとかね
あれやこれやとガチャガチャ言うのであって
なって幸せかということはまた別な話で
みんなそうやって自己の利益で主観的に自分の道を決まっているんです
だから誰一人も 例えば音楽家になりたい人はたくさんいるんだけど
音楽の世界で成功する人っていうのはすごい少ない
画家になりたくて頑張っている人は大勢いるんですけど
画家になってそれで生計を立てて食べていられる人っていうのはまた少ない
医者になってからできれば辞めたい
辞めたいという医者がいくらでもいるんだから
弁護士にすごい難しい
もう日本ではもう試験がまあ別に内容は難しくなんかなくて
ただ単にもうまあ落とすんだから
人々をね で それで でも受ける側にとって難しいでしょうに
やってそれから弁護士になってから
もう毎日悪い嘘を言うインチキ詐欺の人々ばっかりなんやって
この人生って何なのかと
思う人いるますよ で 私にもそういう人がいろいろ相談したりしましたから
医者もいたんだからね
できれば辞めたいと だから自分に何かいいかということは
結局は自分の主観では判断できない
物事は全て主観じゃないので
一つも客観的に科学的に見なくちゃいけない
因果法則なんです 例えば
医者になるということは
ただ技術を学んで患者を体をいじることだけじゃないんです
医者が初めからもう考えなくちゃいけない
この人 医者になったら退職するまで我がままで人格も悪くて
生き方も間違っている
もうだらしない患者にずっと会わなくちゃいけないんですよ
あの事故なんか起こして怪我する人々っていうのは
別に気持ち悪くもなんともないんです
大体あれが悪い これが悪い
がんになりました あれこれというのは
このずっと長い間の生き方でしょうに
それから病気になったら
どんな人間でも私でもすごいわがままになるんですよ
もう調子が悪いんだから
誰かがちょっと話がありますけど
一応ものすごく気分が悪いんです
そんなところじゃないんだよという気分になりますよ
だから普段いい人でも病気になっちゃうと性格が変わる
医者はそれも考えなくちゃいけないので
自分がもう退職するまで
ずっと仲間とって そういう人々と付き合わなくちゃいけないんです
自分にはそういう準備できているのかということ
まあそんなものは決まって決まりきっていることだよとはっきりわかっているならば
医者になって悪かったということは全然ないんですよ
でもそれ考えないで医者ってかっこいいとかね
みんなに尊敬されるんだとかね
かなりでっかな態度でいられるんだとかね
そういうくだらんことを主観的に考えてかっこいいとなっちゃうと
もうかわいそうに 患者さんも大変不幸なことにあるん合うんです
だから 決して物事は自分の主観で判断してはいけないのに
人間にはそれしかできないんでしょうにね
だから助けてあげたってどうにもならない
これがもうこの状態は
私たちには自分の主観でしか判断できない
それがもう私が赤いピンクとか赤いの薬飲みたいと言ったっても
これだったら死んでしまうでしょうね
だから自分の主観で判断して
私の利益は 自己の利益はこれこれですと思って
それを目指して生きているんです
誰も幸福になっていない理由はそれなんです
だから みんな全ての人間が幸福になりたければ
自己の利益は客観的に判断しなくちゃいけないんですね
それで主観で決めただけで実るとは限らない
それもあるでしょうね
自分では決めたんですけど
自分では弁護士になりたいと思ったっても
もうなれない時もあるでしょうし
自分の主観で 主観で言えば
誰でも世界一美人になりたいでしょう
でもなれないでしょうね
自分でそうなりたいと思っただけでは
自分が本当にミスワールドかミスジャパンかミス東京か決めるのは自分じゃないんですよ
結局は それ客観的な判断なんです
だから自分の主観であれこれと思っても
そうなると その気分が実るというと
限らないんですよ 実らない方が多いんです
なぜならば 判断自体がおかしいんだから
だからお釈迦様の話の中で希望は叶わないんだよと
それまた苦しいんだよと
おっしゃっているのはそういうところなんです
やみくもに自己の利益を目指しても実現はできないのです
それで人は正直になっても不正直にという言葉は日本語でありますかね
まあただ勝手に作ってるんですけど
大丈夫ですか なっても損することになっているのです
人間が正直に生きてるって言っても損しますよ
だって 自己の利益のために正直になったのに
結局損する では 不正直になったらどうでしょう
損するんです どちら選んでも
そういうふうになってます
なぜならば 自己の利益という判断基準が正しくない
それは主観的な基準だから
人の成功はたまたまうまくいっただけの話です
世の中で成功している人々いるでしょうね
もうさらにはいないんですけど
それなりにはいる あれがたまたまなんです
たまたまうまくいったと
読んでみてください 成功している人々の話なんかは
その時期が良かったとか
たまたまいい判断ができたとかね
そんなもんでしょ あの
なんとか若い人が科学でノーベル賞を取ったでしょうね
田中 あれもたまたまでしょ
あれこれとガチャガチャガチャガチャやっている時は
もうたまたま出てきたもので
決して自分で計画を立てて
こういうものを発見してやるぞというふうにきちんと頑張ったわけじゃないんです
まあそれでこの あの反論に答えた
反論は私が出して私が答えるんだからね
で 全ての人間が自己の利益を考えているんだったら
全ての人間が幸福 成功しているのは当たり前の理屈ですけど
そうなってないのはこういうわけであると
まあ難しくないんだから進めていきましょう
私は正直者だと これまた
またテーマが変わるんです
あんまりアイディアがなくて
タイトルを変えることはできなかったんです
私は正直者だと宣言することは
社会的な立場からは安全だと
主観的な立場からは自己嫌悪に陥らないという二つの誘惑がある
スタイル変えればもっと分かりやすいんですけど
私は正直者だということで
誘惑二つです いわゆる私が正直だよという
みんな宣言していますよ
人間っていうのは ものは
なぜかというと二つあります
誘惑が 一つは社会的に自分の立場がいいんです
私が信頼できないんだよと言ってみてください
信頼するなよ 私のことはと
どうなるのか 生きていられなくなるでしょうに
だから嘘でも正直だと言わなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから自分の国でも この
どこのどんな仕事に行く場合でも
お寺から招待状を持っていかなくちゃいけないんです
招待状と言ったっても
その人は何者かという
この我々はCertificate of Characterと言うんですけどね
まあどんな人かということは
決してお寺から手紙出せますかね
この人はちょっと心配だとかね
言うこと聞かないんだとかね
書けないでしょうに 仕事を欲しくて
なんとかどこかで面接あるんだからと言ったらね
これはみんな若者でしょうに
そこでもう時々君はどこの家の子ですか？とその時聞くんですよ
住所は何でしょうかと聞いて
こちらにその住所に住んでいるこの子の若者は大変勤勉で
よく真面目で よく信頼できる
責任任すことはできる人であることはここで証明いたしますと
もう判子を押してサインしてあげるんです
で まあ生きる場合はそんなことで
もうあんた初めて見たんだよということは
それが正直なところなんですけど
お寺の住職としてはこの
この この子は初めて見たんですと
それが中東の方にもみんな出稼ぎに行くでしょうね
その時でもやっぱりイスラム教なんですけど
向こうは その時でもお寺から手紙持って来いというんです
それは揃えなくちゃいけない資料の一つなんです
まあキリスト教だったら教会から持っていく
だから我々はどうするかというと
一応それなりの手形 雛形みたいに
一応それなりの文書を作っておいて
名前と住所を入れて書いてあげるんです
方法ないんです だから日にちと名前と住所は一応入れてあって
文面はだいたい同じ それでもうやっぱり正直者だという宣言しなくちゃいけない世界で生きてるんですよ
それで私はちょっとした実験したことがあるんです
昔 全然掃除機じゃないんだと
信頼できないんだと 村でももう追い出されて
もうもうよそ者にしていて
いた若者 いわゆるもう悪ガキということでね
もう何も人の言うこと聞かない
わがままほんぽで 私はこの連中と付き合ってみようと
それで大人たちはみんな私にすごく注意させたんですね
あんた何やってるんでしょうかと
こういう連中は見たもの全部取っていきますよと
盗んじゃいますよと それでまたもう嘘っていうのも平気で言うのに
全然バレないほど上手だよと
ああいうところでああいうことをやった
こういうところでこういうことをやったと
言うは言うは それは気にしない
なぜ仲良くしたんですかというと
信頼できないんだからなんです
それでどうなったかというと
結局は完璧に信頼できるんですよ
面白いことに 私に何でも言うんです
自分がやったいたずらやら
人にやった迷惑やもう何から何
すごく私のところに来て落ち着いてる
私は犯人扱いしてないんだからね
で 話を聞くと 私はなんとなく気持ちわかるんですよ
自分を怒鳴ったりして
何か自分に必要なものも何も協力もしないで追い出したりして腹が立ってるんです
だったら何とかやるぞと言っても
それよりは何倍も損害をさせということなんですけど
でも本人 被害者には全然知らない
バレてない 私は知っている
もう全部 で 私はニコニコと聞くだけで
まあやっぱりそれでせっかく付き合ったんだから
まあ仲良くしたんだからね
この連中もいい人間に
信頼できる人間にしなくちゃいけないということで
まあ私はまず完璧に信頼していると
みんな見ると なかなか性格が変わっている
人に邪魔するところか
一生懸命もう私に対しては水分も守ってくれたりするわ
盗むこと全くないわ もう私がそれで人の仕事も頼む
あれやってください あれやってあげてくださいとか
だからお互いはすごい仲が悪くて喧嘩している間なんです
私は君いて あの人なりやってあげてくださいと
言うと 先生 お坊さん言うならばやりますということで真面目にやってあげる
そういうことではみんなもうそれで
まあやっぱりいい子に育ててるんだということで
今はもう結構大人年ですけど
何の問題もなく生きているんです
だから それは私がちょっとしてやったこの実験みたいなものなんですけど
別に人間が私はなんかちょっと信頼できませんよと宣言したっても
付き合いできない人間ではありませんよ
かえってその方がいいんです
ある人がなんか我々のゴートミ僧正の方に毎日毎日来て
なんか事務所にいて 私は本当はいろいろものを盗むんだよと
それでみんなおびえちゃって
どうしようかとかね もうあっちこっち
いつでも人がいない時もありますから
盗んだらどうしようかというと
ちょっと心配しておびえたりして
うーん でも私はその話聞いたら
だったらその人は信頼できますよと
そう思ったんですけど
だから もしかするとその人がもうお参りに来たんじゃなくて
まあお寺みたいなものだから
もう賽銭箱に何かあるんではないかという気持ちで来たかもしれませんし
同時に本人がちょっと心変わって
自分にはそういう病気があるんだと
だから自分のことを信頼できないんだと前もって言ったことは
普通盗まない人より立派ですよ
それでその人何か盗ったっても
それを盗んだということにならないんです
だからそこまで宣伝した
宣言したならば その人は何とか立ち直るように
普通の社会人で生きていられるように
いろいろ心の闇を直してあげるしかないでしょうに
だから人間が私が正直じゃないんだと宣言したっても悪いわけじゃないんだけど
でも世間で言ってみてください
もうどうなるかと 仏教的に見ればね
その人が信頼できますよ
だって私は正直者だと宣言したっても
正直な人は一人もいないでしょうに
だから正直者だと宣言して
何かおかしいことしたら処理に困るでしょうに
それからもやってない
やってないと言うでしょうに
きめ細かい法律にもう隠れて
あれやこれやと弁護士も頼んでね
いろんなことやるでしょうね
麻原がいまだに自分が最終解脱したと思ってってるでしょうに
だからまあそんなこと言ったっても
我々はやっぱり大体正直者だと宣言している
理由は社会ではうまくいける
それから自分としても気分がいい
自己嫌悪に陥りません
私は正直だというふうな
それもごまかしなんです
従って 正直とは何かと全く理解もできぬまま
人が正直を演じるのです
正直って誰も分かってないでしょうに
それで自分を思う思うままに演じるんです
これが正直 あれが正直とか
これ人間の正直という本当に困ったもんなんですよ
結局は だっていろいろ人の正直はバラバラでしょうに
だからそれが一つの演技なんです
正直者だと言う前に 正直とは何なのかと理解しなくちゃいけない
はい 次に行きます で それからちょっとあの
前回のね ワンチャカダンマということ
今も説明したの一つのワンチャカダンマ
ごまかし機能なんです
を参照します で 怒りタイプの性格のAさんがいるとしましょう
仏教ではそれをドーサチャリタというんですね
我々は性格 基本的なにはある傾きがあるんです
ラーガ 瞑想する時だけここら辺性格分析しますけど
でないと一般的な仏教は人の性格分析はしません
あの 誰かもう弟子入りしたいなんとか言ったら
まあ厳密に性格分析はする
これが人間にわかる世界じゃないんです
見事に微妙にそこら辺ではまあもうなかなか問題
まあ坊主は騙すことはほとんどできん
で それの中で一つのドーサチャリタという性格がある
怒り 傾きが怒りなんですね
でも皆様がそう言った途端
そっちゅうふんふんと怒っていることだと思うでしょう
そうじゃないんです これ微妙なんです
怒りの性格の人はいつでもニコニコと笑っている可能性もあります
いつでも眉毛を もうもうもう何て言いますかね
引き寄って もう嫌な顔をしているわけじゃないんです
微妙なところで判断するんですよ
この性格は 怒ったら怒り
それは誰でもわかります
基本的 この傾き 教えちゃうとあんまり良くないんですけど
やり方はね どうしましょうか
まあ例えばこの机を拭いてくださいと頼む
頼むと雑巾持ってきて拭くんでしょうね
大した仕事じゃないでしょ
誰にでもできるでしょうに
そういう誰にでもできる仕事を頼む
頼んだらそれで見えます
この性格たくさんありますけど
タイプは この人はどんなタイプに入るかっていう
あのメインキャラクターというのは六つありますけど
そこでサブディビジョンズって出てくるとすごくたくさんあります
サブディビジョンに入ってくると一回の仕事でわからない
一応怒りの方が発見する方法を教えます
それでその人が掃除 まず拭くでしょうに
机の上に で 音が出るんです
微妙に あれ ターンとぶつけるんです
それでさっさっさっと拭くんです
で 音は聞こえる いわゆる雑巾と机の面はもうぶつけていくんですね
それはその人のやり方
それだったら怒りの性格なんです
それで見てみると その人はできるだけ早くやろうとしているんです
だから 例えばこちらから一回持っていって
こちらから一回持っていって
また向こうから一回持って三回でできる
その人は見事に三回で終わるんです
それでこちらに行った線とこちらに行った線の間で微妙に拭いてないところは残っているんです
で 雑巾はこうやって水で絞っておくんだから
この水の跡があるんです
それでこの人の心の傾きは怒りだと決めますが
また似ている性格 別な性格もありますから
もう一つ試験があるんです
それで完全に決めることはできません
一応そういうふうな微妙なところなんです
それが欲の傾向ある人に頼んだら
あの音は出てこないんです
しかし 三回ではなくて
もしかすると六回 あるいは八回やるんです
その人は全部拭いてから
次に水の跡もまたもう一回持っていって拭いて置いておくんです
その場合は このラーガチャリタというカテゴリに一応大雑把に入るんです
決定はその後でします
そう簡単じゃないんです
なぜならば 全く同じ性格の
同じく仕事をする別な性格の人もいます
だから これかこれかこれかになるんです
それでかなり少なくなって小さくなりますからね
それで無知の傾向の人もいます
その場合はだいたいわかりやすいことというのは時間かかる
でも時間っていうのはラーガの人と同じかもしれませんけど
ラーガの人はこの見事にこの最後に出来が綺麗に出してやろうということなんです
で 無知な人はその気持ちはないんですけど
ラーガの人ぐらい時間は取ったりする
またあっちこっちちょっとちょっと雑巾が行ってないところもある
もう一つ 例えば長くて
この机だったらあっちからこうやって拭いたりすることもできるし
こういう風に拭くこともできるでしょうに
無知な人だったらこうやって拭いたり
またああいう風に拭いたりもします
いわゆる 何て言いますか
縦に拭いたりして また途中で変えて横に拭いたりしたりする
別に理由がない これラーガの人も両方やる場合
またやり方が違う 縦にやって終わって
跡を消すために横の方にやるんです
そうするとそちらで理由が成り立つんです
それは理由が成り立たない
そういう風に微妙なところでこの性格の傾きを判断するので
だから本人には全然バレないんです
そこでそういうことを教えると
あまり良くないって何で言ったかというと
これ知ってると ではもうしっかりやるぞと思うんですよ
それでもダメです 無理が見えます
だから余計教えてあげちゃうと余計に無理をするという新しい苦しみが付くだけ
そういうわけで 仏教の前ではもう手を上げるしかないんです
そこでそういう今 今説明したような
この微妙な怒りで物にアプローチする人っていうのは
あの性格的には大体物事の欠点
先に見るんですね  [笑い]で
例えばすごく綺麗に飾っている部屋にパーティーに部屋に来たとたん
この風船はここはちょっとダメでしょうと
いきなりそれ見つかるんです
それで その人が 例えば社会の不正的な行為で被害を受けて苦しんでいる
悩んでいる人を彼が見ます
それで 不正行為に対して
被害に対して怒るのですが
怒りには気づかない 自分が怒りの性格ということは性格ということ知らないんだから
なんでこんな不正な行為あるんでしょうかと
こんな人々苦しんでいいのかと
とんでもないことではないかと
本人がそれについて批判したり
話したり アドバイスしたり
いろんなことをするんです
はい 次 直ちに不正を直す行為か被害者を助ける行為をする
行為自体には問題がありません
それを直ちに不正を直そうか
この被害者を何とか助けましょうということで行為をする
それは別に常識的にやっていることだから
別に何の問題もありません
それで社会に認められる結果が出ると
自分が他人に対して親切な人間だと自覚する
例えば その人が被害者を助けることをずっとやっていて
それで被害者も助けられて
それで社会から称賛されるでしょうに
例えば不正行為をやめましょうと運動を起こしちゃうと
で 国民も大賛成して それでそれなりに不正行為をやめてしまったと
すごいでしょうに だからその人は当然ながら社会から称賛される
称賛されると その人はな
自分が自分の力ある限り人々のために頑張りましたと
自分の人生は無駄ではなかったと
よく頑張ったということで
自分が人に対して親切な人間だと自覚するんですよ
でも本当は違うんです
本人わからないんです
そのしかし その人は怒りの衝動で活動しているのです
単なる怒りの衝動で活動しているだけ
で インド人がいないんだからこの例を言います
インドの独立運動してインドを解放したマハトマ・ガンディー
もう神様としてもう崇められていますよ
非暴力主義で イギリス帝国に勝ちました
勝ってインドを独立させたんです
徹しているんですよ 非暴力主義
戦いませんと でもあの人は怒りでやっているんです
本人は知らない 本人はずっと神様にお祈りしながら
みんな仲良くしな みんな仲良くしなさいとかね
なんで喧嘩するのかとかね
それ結構見えます 結局彼もかなり凶暴なんです
ものすごい凶暴 しかし
一言も悪い言葉は言わない
それで華麗にいろいろ誰かが何か言っちゃうと聞かない
喧嘩しちゃうとすぐ断食する
じゃあ死んでやるぞと
それで一般人が ああ こんなこの方が
ガンディージが亡くなっちゃうと
私たちのせいになるんだと
いくら喧嘩したっても
ガンディージをね もうすごい尊敬しているんだから
もうほとんど神様みたいな感じで尊敬されているんだから
これとんでもないことで
それでもう何とかじゃあ仲良くしようと
しかし 仲良くなったわけじゃないんですよ
ガンディージを死なすわけにはいきませんだから
みんな何とかなるだけで
本人が結局はこの根本的にその問題解決しようとしないんです
自分の暴力で抑えるんですよ
だから殺されちゃったんです
だから怒りの結果殺されることなんですよ
なんでガンディー殺されるんですよ
どう見てもおかしいいいところでしょうに
あれほどイスラム教徒も仲がいいし
キリスト教徒も仲がいいし
ヒンドゥー教徒も仲がいいし
あれほど家柄がすごいもう一番上の家柄で金があって
なのにすごい質素な性格を生活をして
自分の財産であろうが何であろうが
全部みんなのために使い尽くして
あれほど頑張ったんだったら
いくらなんでもイギリス人にも殺せなかったでしょうに
あれほどもう何の道徳もないあの人々も
ガンディーが来ると結構もう下がるんです
だからやっぱり行為の結果ですから
これがこの認識機能の働きで本当にややこしいんですよ
だからってガンディーさんが何も貢献してないんですかね
違うでしょうに ガンディーさんがインドにした貢献っていうのは
勝っても今も誰もやってないんですよ
彼のおかげでインドは独立して
インド人のプライドも持てていられるでしょうに
だから結果あるんですよ
私もすごく ものすごい立派な人だとちゃんと賞賛します
でも微妙なところで考えてみると
本人がこの この不正というところで怒ってるんです
それでいい行動に走るんです
走るんだけど 根本的な人格のところは直してないんだから
だからずっと怒りであんまりにも激しく行動しているんだから
怒りで人を殺したわけじゃない
助けたんです でも怒りの結果っていうのは
自分は何かどこかでやられるっていうことなんです
そういう風になるんです
で また前 この前出したスライド同じものなんですよ
で それからこのアッピッチャタ小欲やらね
例えば小欲主義者になる
で なぜ小欲主義者になるかというと
世界はそれを認める 素晴らしいと
だから本人わからない
世界から賞賛されることに引っかかって
自分が小欲主義者になっているんだっていうことはわからない
で それでその人は小欲主義にされて
みんなに説法したり 他の人々にも無駄遣いしないで行して
その残りお金でみんな助けましょうとか何とか言うかもしれません
しかし その人は生かされている衝動が社会から認められ
賞賛されるという欲かもしれません
サントッティッターっていうのは窒息ということで
それもかなり騙しもの働きで
いわゆる窒息を謳ってケチになる
わかりやすい例で言えば
家でいっぱい色んなものあるんですけど
私はほんのちょっとのことで十分満足するんだよと言って使わない
だから 自分知らないうちにケチという物惜しみという機能が機能して
表面的にはすごい常に満足して
質素で生きている立派な人だということになってしまう
それから次に変えて ケチ
物惜しみ パラヌッデータ
アッタサンラクカナタ
パラヌッデータというのは人のことを心配する
例えばケチな人がいる
人にものをあげたくない
それで悩んでいる人々がいるんですよ
あげなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると この人々の生き方が悪い
しっかりしない 仕事はろくにしない
若い時はちゃんと勉強はしなかった
いい加減 仕事に至っても 1週間
2週間で辞める それで今仕事なくて困っている
それで私が助けたらどうなると思いますかね
その人 それでいい気分になっちゃって
それでご飯食べて雑魚するだけで
一向にこの人は自分を直そうとしないでしょう
だからもうちょっと自分がきつい経験した方がいい
助けませんと これ助けないことにする
本人の説法は何かすごいそのらしく聞こえますけど
もともと心には助けたくないという気持ちが隠れているんです
物惜しみが 時々あまり
日本でも何人かから聞いたんですけど
あまり人にものをあげる習慣はないんだから
日本だったら乞食がいないんだからね
友達同士にものをあげることではありません
そうやって人々に乞食たちにお金をあげるということは
乞食を増やすことではないかと
何もあげないと その人々はなんとか仕事をすることになるではないかという話を持ってくる
だからその時でも隠れて言っているのは
乞食のことを心配しているんだ
乞食はとんでもない みんな立派な人間になってほしい
社会人できてほしい だからあげてはいけないんだよという話なんです
わかりやすいんですよ
何もあげなきゃ何もならないんだから
それぐらい乞食を心配するならば
社会人になるために いろんな助けしなくちゃあかんでしょうに
結局あげることは避けられませんよ
仕事をしないで乞食ばっかりやっている人には
もう何かものをあげて
はい 持って行け 帰れ 二度と来るなよということもできるし
それでさらに乞食するんだと
するならば お前仕事を何か勉強しなさい
教えてあげますとかね
あるいは仕事 訓練場何か作ってやりますから
そちらに入りなさいという風に
それでもあげることになるんです
だけど それは避けられません
だからそうやってこの人間というのは
この自分の心を騙すんですね
贅沢 無駄遣いしたい気持ちも欲がないという形を取る
それからこのもう贅沢したい
無駄遣いしたい人々も
やっぱり欲に溺れてるんですよ
美味しいものを見ると
もう食べずにいられない
高価なものを見ると もう我慢できない
買いたい それが明らかなもう欲でしょうね
それで こんなお金であなた何するのかというと
私はケチケチしないよ
お金っていうのはもう使ってもそれで終わるんだから
そんなに執着して貯金してどうなるんでしょうかと
あなた方は 人間というのは楽に生きていなくちゃいけないんだと説法するんです
使いましょうと そこで本人がものに執着してないという格好つ
格好見せるんです 見せるんじゃない
自分に言い聞かせてるんです
私はものに依存しないということで
贅沢の欲に溺れてるんです
溺れてる 本人は知らない
他人と付き合いたいという気持ちも太っ腹性格になるというね
そこでまあそれも欲なんですけど
いろんなたくさん友達作りたい
みんなの中でもワイワイと人気者になっていたい
あの人と付き合いたい
この人と付き合いたいという欲があるんです
それが私はもうやっぱりもう一人で食べたり遊んだりするのは
これはけしからん やっぱりみんながみんなにも楽しみを与えなくちゃいけないということで
自分がどこかのレストラン行くならば
電話かけて一緒にどうでしょうかとかね
今日はフランス料理食べたいと思ってますけど
まあ一緒に行きましょうよと
で 強引にでも友達を呼んでご馳走させてあげる
ご馳走してあげるでしたっけ
してあげる 友達もすごい
もうこんなことは願ってもないことで大変ということでね
こんな美味しいものは自分ではもう絶対もう考えられませんと
食べるっていうことはとかね
と言うかもしれません
しかし それでその人がそうやってもう自分を離せない仲間を作るんです
それでいい気分でいるんです
だから自分が太っ腹と
だから表面的に決して悪いことじゃないんだけど
この心の中を見ると まあただいろんな人と付き合いたいだけということで
この太っ腹の金ある男たちとかね
いろんな女の人にバッグ買ってあげたり
ネックレスを買ってあげたり
次にどうなるかとわかってるでしょうに
はい で これも前も出したスライドばっかしです
それで私はちょっとした
ちょっと楽をしたんです
メッタ 友情も騙す場合ありますよ
また同じくいろんな人と付き合いたい
それで友情とメッタ演じる
私は慈悲を実践しているんだから
まあみんな仲間でしょうとかね
言って慈悲を実践するということで
結構たくさん友達を作ってしまう
それで慈悲と同時にいろいろ自分の希望も叶ってもらうでしょう
そこでバレるはずなんですけど
自分が人に優しいか その人のことを好きで
その人から何か得を得ようとしているのではないかという
本当に私はこの人を好きですか？この人のこと可愛くて欲でついてるかということはあまり気にしない
あなたのこと心配してるんだと言いながら
もういろいろ出来事も起こる
だからその場合も欲が慈悲として隠れる
欲が隠れて慈悲で慈悲の顔をする
メッターの顔をする だからそういうことを勉強しないと
結構トラブル起こりますよ
例えば慈悲を実践するんだぞと言ってね
どんな人でも友達ではないか
友人ではないかとか なんとかなんとか
そういうふうないい加減な生き方をすると
いろいろトラブル起こりますよ
心が綺麗でなかったら
すごい怖い人をまあまあ仲良くしましょうと
どうせ仲良くしている癖があるんだから
簡単に仲良くなったりする
それからもうちょっと言っちゃうんですね
それはもう隠れ機能でワンチカダーマで自分を騙されているということ
こちらはね 異性に特に優しいと書いたんですからね
みんなと仲良くしましょうという
どうか異性の方には結構慈悲があるという
で カルナというのは憐れみ
苦しんでいる人を助けるということで
困っている異性に対してはあえて優しい状態になるとかね
私は苦しい 困っている人を見たら
本当に見ていられないんだ
と言って 本当に困っている人は助ける
でも今までどれぐらい助けてきたなと調べてみたら
どうもちょっと異性にはもう結構優しく助けたことがいっぱいあったりして
会社でも 例えば男と女が同じ失敗したら
もう二人とも同じ口調で怒鳴られるのは普通なんですけど
女性が結構可愛いんだったら
その時はすごくなんかもう物分かりのいい人で
まあ人間っていうのはね
まあそういう少々失敗しますけど
君まあこれからちゃんと頑張ってください
まあどうったことはない
やり直してちょうだいという風に言って
男の人お前何だとこれという
その時は物分かりじゃないんですね
感情で だからそういうふうな生き方で
結局は自分を騙すんですね
はい これで忍耐ということもありましてね
忍耐だと怒りを隠す 私は忍耐しています
それをクシャンティというカーンティですね
仏教でいかに立派なことではないかと
で よくわかるケースというのは
この自分がすごい頑固
全くも自分の生き方を変えたくない
頑固っていうのは悪い性格なんですよ
育てないっていう意味だからね
それで頑固な人は悪いことするでしょうに
だからカンカンもう怒られたり怒鳴られたりするでしょうに
でもじっと聞いている
それで友達があんたあれほど罵られたのに
よくも一言も言い返さなかったんですねと言ったら
何の何のこともないよ
人間というのは忍耐するんだよと
あんた方もよく私を見習って
何言われたっても一言も言い返すことをしないで
怒らずじっと耐えた方がいいだよと言って偉い顔をするんですよ
本当はあれ 忍耐ではないんです
頑固なんです 自分を変えたくないんです
子供もそういうことをよくやりますからね
[背景音楽]それでアヒンサーっていうのは
それまた仏教で言っている素晴らしい道徳で
害を与えないということ
それでこの暴力振るいたい人がいる
いわゆる怒りの人がいる
でも怒っちゃうと怒りよくないと本人も知っている
でも基本的な傾向は怒り
本人はわからない それでいきなり私はアヒンサー主義者
アヒンサー素晴らしいと
非暴力主義っていうのはとてもいいことだと
すごいそれに未練を感じる
例えば仏教の話でも読んだら
まあ誰にも害を与えませんと
良い人は立派な人は 自己を戒める人は
他人に害を与えないというブッダの言葉はいろいろあります
それを聞いて やっぱりそういうふうにやらなくちゃと自分で真面目に決める
決めて そういうふうに生き方するんですよ
しかし よくよく見るとどうなるかというと
もう正義の味方になっている
暴力振るってはあかんでしょうと言って
例えばいじめる人に対して
そんなのはよくないでしょうと
いい加減やめろとか言って
そちらに暴力ふる 言って
やっぱり君たちはみんな仲良ししなさい
人間ってそういうことではないかと
それであまりにも怖いんだから
もういじめる側もいじめをやめますよ
で それって何なのかというと
やっぱり本人が暴力非暴力主義者というよりも
自分の怒りを非暴力主義という出口から発散しているんです
だから出口が綺麗だから誰にもバレないんです
世間に見せる顔は本当に非暴力主義行為ということなんです
そこで中にある怒りはそれで発散する
よくあることで この安楽死といって
動物は平気で殺す ヨーロッパ
アメリカとか映画でもよくあるでしょうにね
もうなんのことなくパッと撃ち殺す
ペットでも何でも病気にかかったりなんとかになったりしちゃうと
すぐ撃ち殺す 時々人間殺すケースも映画なんかにあるんですね
随分仲のいい友達がなんとかに引っかかっちゃって
かなりひどい目に遭っちゃって
もう生き返ることもなく
例えば戦場でもう怪我してなんとかとかね
置いておくわけにもいきませんし
持ってもいかないし もうかなり激しい状態で
で まあということで友達に頼まれて一発撃つとかね
結局人殺しなんですよ
でも本人がすごく悩んでやったからね
友達のためにやったとかね
自分が悪いことしていないというふうにする
動物を殺す場合でも 結局はあれがもう怒りであって
苦しんでるんだからといって安楽死させてあげましょうと
それこそその人のために
動物にとっていいことではないかというのも
まああれはごまかしなんです
それで日韓またこの前も明確に説明しましたから
今日はそれはやめます
で 次に行きます それからHow do we meet ourselves?まあ我々はそんなもんなんですよ
なんか心の中でいっぱいごまかしがあるんです
では自分にどうやって会いましょうかと
これに行く前にもうちょっと
まあ時間はもうないね
じゃあこれいきましょう
いくらか説明したところありますけど
まず心は何ものかと覚えておきましょう
自分に会うということは自分の心に会うことだから
で ファーストステップというのは
自分心は何ものかと覚えておくことです
それはもうずっと読めばいいんです
はい それで終わり 心っていうのは複雑で
また逃げ回る心 これ複雑ですね
ここは文脈がちょっと間違ってますけど
複雑です また 逃げ回る心を発見することは至難の業です
だからガンディさんの例にしたっても
これ至難の業です また言ってはいけないことでしょう
ガンディさんもすごい怒り
で活動すると 要するに逆に言ってもいけないことなんですよ
だから自分でも発見するのは難しいし
すごい逃げ回る心は すぐ変身する
心は自分を発見して欲しくないのです
心っていうのは決して自分を発見して欲しくない
自分っていうのは心が強者で
常に正しいと思う それまた心の特色なんです
私が強いと と正しいと
隠れて他を巧みに管理すれば良いと思っている
自分の心っていうのは
自分が隠れて他人を管理するんですよ
巧みに 人間みんなそれやってるでしょうに
自分は何者か見せないで
見事な人を管理しているんです
だから 税金いっぱいごまかして贅沢したい人でも
国民のためにと言って政治に参加することがありますよ
見事にごまかすんです
本人も本気で国のためにと思っている可能性もあります
しかし 実際は国のため
国のため 国のためと言いながら
よくよくやってみると
自分のためにいっぱいことをやっている
例えば一般の日本の方々の
あれ何と言いますか 年取ったらもらう
国 年金 ほとんどもらえない状態にしてしまって
議員さんたちにはもう二重
三重 四重構造で 年金も退職金も何でももらうという
絶対変えませんね だからやっぱり心っていうのは
それで巧みに他人を管理する
はい しかし 人の行動で心は常に表に出ているのです
で 我々は自分のことを隠しているんだと思っているんですけど
結局はバレてバレバレなんです
隠せないんですよ 心は
ただ自分が知らないだけ
だから他人に言われるとすごく怒るでしょ
他人には明確に見えますよ
例えばアホなことしたら
これはアホなことだと他人がちゃんと知ってるでしょうに
だから「これがなんてアホなことする
あんた相当アホではないか」と言われるとすごく怒るんです
なぜならば 自分の心の中で「私はアホではありません」と
いう気分があるんです
もうとっくに全部バレてるんですよ
丸裸なんです 心っていうのは
一番分かりやすいのは人の心なんです
隠れてるつもりだけです 「
私の気持ちなんかあなたには
あなたにはわからない」という場合も
ほとんど他人にわかっているのです
それよく言われる話でしょ
女性の方々 よく旦那に対してもそれを言うでしょうに
旦那はわかってるんだから逃げてるだけ
もう聞かないことにしようと
話すらす そうと まあ一般的に男っていうのはそんなに言葉上手でもないし
あの あの体の構造からも
男は喋るためにはすごい体力使うんですよ
女性は何の体力も使わないで何時間でも喋れます
だからそういう欠点もあります
私でもかなり疲れますよ
だからどうしても まあ特に男もよく喋りますけど
夫婦関係になってくると
まあ大体言葉が少ない
よく喋るのはこの誰か
もう新しく恋人を作ると
もう自分のものになるまでは喋ります
その時はもう体力は惜しまない
自分のになってからはもう黙ってるんです
それで女性たちもよく言うのは
あなたなんか私の気持ちわかってないとかね
わかってるんですよ だったらなんであの文句言うかというと
あのわかってる気持ちではなくて
別なものをわかってほしいんです
それどういうことかというと
それも誤魔化しなんですよ
例えば 自分がすごく嫉妬しているんです
それ隠して もう例えば時々旦那に対しても嫉妬する場合あるんですよ
旦那がもういくらかかっこよくて
いつでも外へ出ると決まってしっかり出ていったりすると
まあ一人で出ていくでしょうね
これがもう気に入らん
それでガチャガチャガチャガチャ家に帰ったらいろんなことを言う
言ってもいくらかわかってるんで
自分が外へ出かけたことに
一人でいろいろ用事があって出かけただけで
まあ自分がもうおしゃれで決まるのはもう若い時からもやってることだから
もうこれはやめたくはないし
で まあそれに言うんだよとわかってます
だから話を逸らしたりする
自分でその生き方変えたくないでしょうに
そうすると あなたなんか私の気持ちはわかってないんだと言うんです
なぜかというと この女性がもうあなた家のことは心配しないではないかとかね
あんたもうちょっと親切にした方がいいんじゃないか
そんなこと言うんですよ
それで本当はそうじゃないんです
これ単なる嫉妬なんです
これバレてるんだから
あなたにわかってほしいのはそういうことじゃないんだよと
私はあなたのことを心配しているんだとわかってほしいと
心配してないんだから
だからわかってないともう叫ぶんです
気持ちをわかってほしくないということを言ってるだけです
結局は 嫉妬ばれちゃってはほしくない
別なことを理解してほしかったということなんです
はい それから 2番目の
1番目に言ったのは 人間の心は何ものかと理解してほしい
今までそれ説明してたんですよ
とんでもない心なんです
それを理解してから またさらに心のことなんですけど
これも理解してほしい
心は完璧ではありません
あるはずもないんです
何でも正しく知るわけでもありません
心で知ってる知ってると思ったっても
一つも正しく知ってないんです
だって正直ということの意味さえも知らないでしょうに
基本的には無知という感情で機能しているのです
心っていうのは無知で動いてるんです
知らないということで動いているんです
知らないんだったら知ればいいのに
知らないんだから何かアホなことするだけですよ
心は それでそれに欲と怒りが加わります
無知に 本来の心はだから不浄なものですよ
本来の心というのは無知と欲と怒りなんです
強者ではなくて弱者なのです
心っていうのは だから隠れるんですよ
はい で  2番目の続き 弱者の故に隠れようとする
弱者だから 弱者でありながら自分を管理している
弱さたる心が自分を管理しているんですよ
だからもうろくな結果になってないんです
したがって 人生はいつでも納得いかないものになっているのです
なんで人生なっている納得いかないんでしょうかね
これは弱さたる心に管理しているんだからなんです
納得いくわけじゃないんです
2番目に 心は本来正しいものではないと知っておきましょう
だから  2番目のステージは
心は正しいものではございませんと
自分の心は 理解してほしい
それでサードステップ
それから心を次の仕事に行く
悪を発見する みんなそれやらない
逆を善を発見しようとしてるでしょうに
私はいい人やとかね 私はこういういいことをしているんだぞとか逆をしてほしい
私はこういう悪いことをしているんだ
こういう悪いことをしてみるんだとかね
心は本来不浄だから難しくないんだよ
それは ちょっと見れば悪しか出てこないということになるんです
しかし 心の騙し機能が働くからやる気にはならない
やる気にはならない もう悪を見たくないんです
やっぱり逆に私はいい人間だと
なんとかしていい人間だと言いたくなるんですよ
そんなにもいい人間だと言いたくなるのはやっぱり弱いでしょうに
弱いんだからなんです
例えば肩書きやらあれやこれやといろんなもので自分を出そうとする人は心が弱いんですよ
それでサードステップ
で また続き それでこの発見する方法ですよ
欲 怒り 怠け 嫉妬 我がまま
落ち込みなど もうたくさんありますよ
自分の心見てみると いくらでもあります
自分にわかるとわかる心の悪を発見して認めていく
自分にわかるということは
あまり厳密にアビダンマテキストを開けてはいけません
それもやっている方々いるんですけど
それが騙し機能なんです
ただ単純に生々しく自分がわかるものでいいんです
これが嫉妬だ これが怒りだとかね
わかるぐらいでいいのよ
これは落ち込みだとかね
これが怠けだとかね わかる範囲でいいんです
自分を良くしようという努力はこの場合は要りません
踏ん張ってよくいい人間になってほしくないんです
ただ悪を認めるだけ いい人間になっちゃうとどうなるかわからないんだからね
冗談で言うんですけど
これは真剣なプロセスなんです
ただし そこで良いところもあるのですが
とりあえずそれを後回しにする
人間に良いところありますよ
マハトマ・ガンジーにも素晴らしい良いところあったんですけど
だから我々にもありますよ
でもそれは発見するんじゃなくて
後回しにしてほしい まず悪だけ発見してほしい
なぜ後回しにするかというと
私もなかなかということになるんですよ
調子に乗るんですよ 捨てたもんじゃないんだと
そうしちゃうと決して心は治らないんですね
で  4番目に それから 4番目の仕事に入れます
悪を正直に認められる勇気を持つ
それで悪を発見すると嫌になるでしょう
悪しかないんだから でもまあ発見してやるぞという勇気が次についてほしい
なぜかというと 私が悪かったという人って
すごい勇気ですよ いえ
私ではありませんというのはもう弱い人ですよ
え これが私がやったんだよというのはかなり勇気なんです
だから悪を発見しながら同時に勇気も育ててほしい
それから客観的に物事を判断する
これちょっと難しいかもしれません
だけど 自分の主観で判断しないで
何でも客観的に客観的に判断する
悪は勝手に減っていかない場合は
この勝手に減るんですよ
面白いことに 悪を発見すると発見すると
その悪いこと勝手に減っていくんです
それもあの騙し機能が見事に騙してるんです
お釈迦様が 心にすごいべったしで騙し機能があるんです
それでお釈迦様が騙し機能を騙す方法でやっているんです
だからどうしてもいい人間になるんです
だから 自分の悪を発見すると
何の努力しなくても悪がどんどんどんどん減っていくんです
減っていかない場合は
それでも粘り強くある場合は
自分の良いところも確認する
で 悪を善で置き換えることを試す
そのあまりにも粘り強く
質が悪くて どうしても悪が確認してもしても減らない場合は
私は悪だけじゃないんではないかと
いろいろいいところも私にあるんじゃないかと
置き換えてやるぞという風に
その時だけなんですよ
自分の良いところを確認するの
あまりにも粘り強く悪が消えない時
はい 次 で 番目 自己紹介
それでやっと自分に会ったら自己紹介しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
自分というのは何なのかと
あらゆる感情が混じり合って自分が生きている
自分というのはもう怒りもあるわ
欲もあるわ 人を助ける気持ちもあるわ
もういろんなもの混じり合ってますよ
わがままもあるわ 同時に人のことを心配もするわ
まあごちゃごちゃ混じり合ってるんです
それが自分なんです 自分の性格を定めるのは難しい
性格は全く定められません
仏教で言うあの基本的な傾向っていうのは
なかなか一般人にはわからない
本人にもわからない しかし
自分が何者かということを自分でも定められないんですよ
時々怒って怒鳴って もうカンカンもうものすごい激しく行動して
時々すごい親切に行動する
時々全くバカバカらしいことをするんですけど
また時々すごいしっかりと物事を考えても行動する
だから自分の人格っていうのは全く定められてない
ぐるぐる変わるんだよということが自分なんです
その時の条件によって反応するだけ
嫌なことをかけたらすぐ怒る
綺麗なものを見たらすぐニコッと笑うという
なんかロボットみたいに自分というのは
気づけば決まってる反応を変えることもできる
しかし 気づけば変えられます
我々は嫌なことだったら自動モードで怒るでしょうし
ちょっと気づけば怒らないでもいられます
すごい美しいものを見たら欲しいと思うのはオートなんですね
ロボットみたいに我々はそういう風に反応する
しかし 気づけば別になくてもいいんじゃないかなということもできますよ
それを勉強してほしい
それが自分の能力なんです
それから自分というのは悪に落ちやすい
どんな人間も悪いことをしやすいんですよ
堕落しやすいんです ちょっとちょっと緩んだらもう堕落してるんです
それが人間 本来の人間なんです
で 自己紹介の続き それで終わりとは言いますけど
条件によって自分の心が終わる
変わることと そのシステムを分かったところは
自分が自分に出会ったことです
それでも自分に出会ったということなんです
条件によって私が変わりますよと
例えば 「あんた優しい人ですか？」と聞かれたら 「
いえ そうじゃない 条件によって優しくなる場合もあります」と
条件によってえらい凶暴になる時もありますよと
という風に正直に自分のことは分かっている
それから なんで人が凶暴になる？私はどんな時凶暴になるのか
私はどんな時欲張りになるのか
私はどんな時怒るのか
私はどんな時怠けるのかとか
そのシステム 心の 分かったらもう自分が分かったことなんです
それで自分に出会ったことですね
そういうことで まあそれで
私たちには自己に出会うことはできます
はい 今日は終わり どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます